wie wichtig ist dieses System für die
Ukraine
ja es ist natürlich ein symbolischer Akt
weil Patriots mit Abstand eines der
leistungsfähigsten Abwehrsysteme
überhaupt ist also für für die Abwehr
von Marschflugkörpern von Michaels auch
von Drohnen und das zeigt natürlich dass
die weder die Ukraine noch die
Unterstützer der Ukraine sich abfinden
werden mit der verbrecherischen
russischen Krieg Führung die ja in
letzter Zeit darauf gesetzt hat eben mit
solchen marschflughörnern die zivile
Infrastruktur und die
Energieinfrastruktur anzugreifen das ist
also schon ein Zeichen dass man sich von
Russland in den Sinne nicht beeindrucken
lässt und dass man die Ukraine auch
entsprechend ausstattet um diese
Angriffe zu werden eine Frage kommt von
Chris Watts via Youtube auf dieses
Patrick System überhaupt gegen diese
kleinen Drohnen aus dem Iran effektiv
sind
ja also so klein sind die Drohnen nicht
also sie meinen die schahit 136 doch
doch also die radareinheit kann die
schon erkennen und auch entsprechend
abfeuern die Frage ist jetzt ob sie das
Patriot unbedingt dagegen einsetzen
würden weil das das wäre so von Kosten
Nutzen Vergleich her eine relativ teure
Art und Weise Drohnen zu bekämpfen wenn
sie jetzt aber die charit 136 anschauen
die ist ja erstens relativ laut und
zweitens fliegt sie auch relativ langsam
also da brauchen Sie nicht unbedingt das
Patriot und die abzufangen alles in
allem ist dieses Patrick System für den
momentan Verlauf dieses Krieges in
diesem Winter der Zeit ein gamechanger
also es ist sicher eine eine Ergänzung
der derzeitigen ukrainischen Luftabwehr
aber ein gamechanger in dem Sinn ist es
nicht weil es es verbessert natürlich
die die Verteidigung vor allem der
zivilen Infrastruktur aber von
gamechanger kann man erst sprechen wenn
tatsächlich in diesem Winter oder
wahrscheinlicher im nächsten Frühjahr
die nächste Initiative der Ukraine los
geht und dann wäre die Frage was werden
dann für Waffensysteme geliefert also im
Moment ist es denke ich eher ein ein
symbolischer Akt der auch klar das
Commitment zeigt der USA und ihrer
westlichen Partner die Ukraine weiter zu
unterstützen es ist ein guter und
wichtiger Schritt man muss aber auch
sagen dieses Paket enthält natürlich
mehr als nur das Patriot und das das ist
eigentlich so die Richtung ähm sie haben
es gerade gesagt und MRT wir sind zum
einen gegangen zwei Milliarden 1,8
Milliarden groß ungefähr dieses Paket da
ist eine Menge drin das ist weiß Gott
nicht nur dieses Patrick System unter
anderem geht es auch um einen jdam
Waffentyp klingt erstmal viel sagend was
genau steckt dahinter und inwieweit ist
das wichtig zu wissen
ja das ist ein ganz interessanter
Waffentyp man kann sich das vorstellen
ein bisschen wie ein ikea-bausatz also
die Idee ist
Präzisionswaffen sind ja schwierig
herzustellen und auch teuer also nimmt
man einfach sogenannte dumme Bomben also
einfache Explosivkörper und schraubt an
die ein Heck und ein GPS leitgerät dran
und damit hat man aus einer dummen Bombe
mit relativ wenig Einsatz und vor allem
sehr schnell eine präzisionswaffe
gemacht die hat eine Reichweite von
ungefähr 30 km ähm das heißt also es ist
eher für den für den nahe Einsatz
geeignet und so wie sie konzipiert es
jetzt vor allem von Trägersystem aus der
Luft abgeschossen
das ist interessant weil die Ukraine
damit in die in die Lage versetzt wird
eigentlich ein ein Großteil ihrer
Munition zu konvertieren in ihn recht
billiger und schneller Weise in
Präzisionswaffen das heißt also sie
brauchen jetzt nicht mehr so lange und
warten bis sie bis sie Nachschub zum
Beispiel für die heimatsysteme haben sie
brauchen nicht mehr teure
Präzisionsraketen einsetzen sondern dass
das verändert dann schon die die lokalen
Realitäten denke ich was man aber auch
sehen muss gerade an die Adresse derer
sage ich dass die in letzter Zeit immer
wieder von sogenannte Munitionsmangel
gesprochen haben dieses Paket ist vor
allem voll mit Artillerie und mit
Artillerie Munition und man muss eines
ganz klar sehen was im Westen derzeit
passiert ist die die westlichen
Rüstungsindustrie werden angeworfen um
entsprechend nach zu produzieren und das
ist ein Effekt den man langfristig nicht
unterschätzen darf weil bisher für
Russland ja den Krieg aus seinen
Reserven und die große Frage die sich ab
nächstem Jahr stellen wird ist die
leistungsfähig sind die jeweiligen
Rüstungsindustrie das heißt was passiert
wenn die Lage ein Mann leer sind dann
stellt sich nämlich die Frage wer kann
logistisch länger durchhalten und wer
kann mehr und besser produzieren und ähm
natürlich auch mit der Frage sozusagen
es muss Menschen geben die das machen
und die wollen müssen auch gewollt
gewillt sein dass irgendwie zu machen
aber genau dazu was sie gerade sagen ich
fass mal ein paar Fragen zusammen was
wäre denn so ein gamechanger im Krieg
sie haben es schon angedeutet aber
vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen
expliziter und auch die Frage wer
Youtube von von aige ob deutsche
Panzerlieferungen Leopard Marder all das
was immer schon wieder mal diskutiert
wird und im Raum steht ob das für diesen
Winter Kriegs entscheidend sein könnten
also gamechanger die die zweite Frage
beantwortet ist eigentlich schon wenn
die Ukraine die Russen mit Gewalt aus
ihrem Staatsgebiet herauswerfen will
dann braucht sie offensivmittel und das
primäre offensiv Mittel sind nun mal
Kampfpanzer und es gibt weder technische
noch politische Gründe diese Kampfpanzer
nicht zu liefern es gibt nur einen
einzigen Grund nämlich wenn sie in
Deutschland dann schon die Weigerung des
deutschen Bundeskanzlers ist zu tun die
Amerikaner haben mehrfach signalisiert
dass Sie nichts dagegen haben auch
dieser Einwand mit dem sogenannten
Alleingang zählt nicht mehr also das das
hat nun wirklich nur noch politische
oder vielleicht emotionale Gründe und
ich ich vermute auch in falsches
russlandbild aber wenn sie schon in
welche Phase kommen wir jetzt hinein in
den Krieg wir kommen in eine Phase
hinein in der die Ukraine die Initiative
hat und sie ausnutzen muss
spätestens im Frühjahr 23 denn sie hat
nicht so viele Zeitfenster in denen Sie
diese Offensive führen kann und dafür
braucht sie offensiv Mittel und wenn Sie
nun die Lager voll haben mit Gerät dass
sie ohnehin nicht brauchen
beziehungsweise dass sie relativ einfach
liefern könnten dann stellt sich
wirklich langsam aus deutscher sich die
Frage warum tun sie es nicht in wie
gesagt abholen Baltikum sieht das völlig
anders die Frage dazu deswegen habe ich
vorhin ja auch schon mal unterbrochen an
der Stelle aber ich halte es für wichtig
klar Washington Brüssel
liefern und wir sehen das gerade heute
ich habe es eingangs gesagt das ist ein
Tag an dem große Weichen gestellt werden
aber auch Moskau tut es ja und hat heute
mit dem was Putin gesagt hat sehr
unmissverständlich zu verstehen gegeben
dass man gewillt ist an allen Zielen
fest zu halten kostet es was es wolle
das ist etwas wo hinterher nicht zurück
kann ohne Gesichtsverlust und das ist ja
das was bei Verhandlungen gilt immer
auch zurücksichtigen
wie kann ein Kompromiss aussehen wie
kann eine Lösung aussehen in diesem
Konflikt welche Perspektive gibt es
überhaupt wird dort jetzt aufgerüstet
werden da jetzt ein Ost-West-Konflikt in
der Uhr in den in der Ukraine
ausgetragen mit mehr Waffen mit mehr
Munition mit mehr atillerie auf Kosten
der Bevölkerung
[Musik]
ich muss das ein bisschen aufgliedern
also zunächst mal hält Putin sicher an
seinem ideologischen narrativfest er
würde jetzt quasi Krieg gegen die NATO
führen ja also nach dem Motto eigentlich
hätte er diesen Krieg in drei Tagen
schon gewonnen gehabt aber dummerweise
ist dann die ganze NATO auf ihn
losgegangen und jetzt muss er sich
leider gegen die ganze NATO wären es
gibt übrigens auch in Deutschland und im
Westen nicht wenige Kreml Propagandisten
und selbst ernannte Experten die dieses
narrativ verbreiten ich muss dann immer
ein bisschen schmunzeln und sagen wenn
wirklich die NATO äh hier angreifen
würde mit ihrem gesamten Material zu
Land zu Wasser und zu Luft dann wäre
dieser Krieg in zwei Tagen vorbei dann
gäbe es keine russische schwarz mehr
Flotte mehr und dann müssen wir uns über
vieles gar nicht mehr unterhalten also
zunächst mal das das ist nicht so dass
sie irgendeinen Stellvertreter Krieg der
NATO stattfindet ähm es ist immer noch
eine russische Aggression gegen die sich
die Ukraine wehrt und jeder startet hat
nach Artikel 51 der unkater das Recht
die UK dabei zu unterstützen also so
viel mal zu den Fakten
und wenn sie jetzt schauen näher ist ist
Russland dazu in der Lage also ich meine
Russland ist in diesen Krieg hinein
gestolpert und müht sich nun seit 300
einem Tag ab irgendwelche Kriegsziele zu
definieren oder zumindest irgendetwas zu
erreichen das wird für Putin zunehmend
zum Problem weil irgendwann muss ja mal
Resultate vorweisen und solche
Veranstaltungen wie diese die dienen in
Russland nun eben dazu dass die
Führungspersonen entsprechend Stärke
zeigen kann und und signalisieren kann
ich bin hier immer noch der Chef und ich
sage Russland geht damit versucht er so
ein bisschen die Verantwortung für den
Krieg von sich abzuwälzen und zu sagen
ja ich kann ja nichts dafür wenn die
Rüstungsindustrie nicht liefert oder
wenn man ihn kompetenter
Verteidigungsminister das nicht
hinbekommt also solche solche
Veranstaltungen sind eigentlich typisch
für die russische Umgangskultur die
Frage ist dann nur der Unterschied
zwischen russischen Ankündigungen und
russischen Realitäten also Stichwort
ineffizient zum Korruption in der
leistungsindustrie ich bin da doch recht
skeptisch ob den Russen das gelingt eine
ähnliche Geschwindigkeit und Intensität
der Aufrüstung zu erreichen wie es den
westlichen Industrien demnächst gelingen
wird wir sprechen gleich weiter
vielleicht bei der Gelegenheit wollen
wir noch mal hören was Putin heute
gesagt hat um uns auch da buchstäblich
ein Bild zu machen und Augenzeuge zu
sein denn er hat auch heute wieder von
Atomwaffen gesprochen und Möglichkeiten
die es demnach demnächst geben soll
das Niveau der Bewaffnung auch immer
thomarenbereich ist schon über 91
Prozent weiterhin werden wir die Truppen
umstrukturieren wir haben einen modernen
nuklearen Bereich mit ultra Schall
Avantgarde Zukunft werden wir zum ersten
Mal interkontinentale ballistische
raketenz liefern
Markus Keup ist das atomare selber
Rasseln einmal mehr
nein das sind eigentlich Programme die
es schon lange gibt also der der
Avantgarde das ist ein Hyperschall
Flughafen der wird schon seit
Jahrzehnten eigentlich
definiert und und entwickelt also die
Ursprünge da die gehen zurück bis in die
70er Jahre die saß
und auch die die andere die haben's
Rakete sind interkontinental Raketen die
ebenfalls schon ich glaube seit 20 17 im
Programm sind und in der Entwicklung
also das ist nicht wirklich irgendwas
neues Russland testet auch immer wieder
und interkontinental Raketen diese Tests
werden entsprechend angekündigt bei den
Generalstäben also sprich wenn die
Russland das macht wissen die USA das
ähm nein also neu ist das nicht es kann
sein dass das jetzt vielleicht manche
Leute Angst macht weil sie das einfach
nicht wissen aber ähm ich sage das immer
wieder es gibt keine Änderungen in der
nuklearen Bereitschaft Russlands es gibt
nichts was die Satelliten irgendwie
finden die diese Lage überwachen es gibt
keine Zusammenführung der Sprengköpfe
mit den Trägersystemen also nein es ist
nicht mal selber raus sondern es ist die
Wiederholung des bekannten würde ich
sagen
wir schauen vielleicht noch mal gerade
schnell ins Weiße Haus bei der
Gelegenheit weil es noch mal Bilder gibt
vom Oval Office wenn die Regie das
vorlegen kann und dann können wir
weitersprechen da sehen wir es also
selensky sitzt mit beiden im Oval Office
es ist gemütlich angerichtet sage ich
mal und ich meine es nicht flapsig
sondern ich glaube auch das hat alles
Symbolwert was da gemacht wird also man
sitzt bei Kaminfeuer im weihnachtlich
geschmückten Orgel Office während sie
Lenski dort im olivgrünen Anzug sitzt
auch das ist ja ein Bild mit einer
Aussage Kraft es wird spannend sein zu
beobachten was nachher bei der
Pressekonferenz rauskommt und wie groß
dieses Paket drin ist und auch mit
welchen Worten ist sozusagen geschmückt
wird und wie entschlossen beiden sich
auch Richtung Moskau äußern wird
vielleicht an der Stelle noch mal weiter
auch Putins rechte Hand mit Videos ich
hatte es eingangs gesagt war heute in
Peking unterwegs an diesem großen Tag an
dem vieles passiert bei Staatsschiff Ski
china hat ja in letzter Zeit mehrfach
klar gemacht dass es keine Atom kein
atomaren Waffeneinsatz geben darf keine
atomare Bedrohung auch heute wurde noch
mal darauf hingewiesen dass er keine
Option aber dennoch hat mir den Eindruck
Russland sucht auch in Fernost den
Schulterschluss
ja und und das sagt eigentlich recht
viel aus über die Verhandlungsmacht bzw
die strategische Größe Russlands oder
sagen wir mal das was davon übrig ist
es ist schon so dass China spätestens
seit Mai zunehmend auf Distanz gegangen
ist zu Russland das heißt die Chinesen
Pragmatiker wie sie sind nehmen gerne
die billigen Rohstoffe an das Öl mit
großen discount und genauso auch das Gas
und Flüssigkeit aber sie sagen Putin
auch ganz klar wo die Grenzen sind unten
ich habe ja schon im März diesen Jahres
gesagt wurde übrigens recht heftig
angefeinde dafür dass Russland
irgendwann zu Chinas billiger kleiner
Tankstelle werden wird und ich denke wir
sehen zunehmend Anzeichen dass ich die
Dinge in diese Richtung entwickeln ich
glaube nicht dass ehrlich gesagt eine
gestellt wie man wird jetzt die ja nicht
mehr zu vergleichen ist mit den Jahren
Präsident war das also eine Gestalt die
die wirklich nur noch die hässlich
Propaganda auf telegram von sich gibt
nun dahin nach China geschickt wird das
ist kein besonders glaubwürdiges Zeichen
erstens und zweitens sind es eigentlich
die Chinesen die im Moment den Russen
den Tarif durchgeben das heißt was sie
gewillt sind zu akzeptieren und was
nicht kommen wir vielleicht abschließend
und auch da noch einen Kommentar von
emsch Müller via Youtube niemand außer
der Ukraine selbst hat das Recht zu
entscheiden wann es zu Verhandlungen
kommen soll wir haben heute noch nicht
viel von Verhandlungen gehört Elmar
Tierwesen sagt es vorhin es soll keine
Direktive geben aus Washington Richtung
Ukraine wir haben jetzt über Moskau und
über Peking gesprochen ist das heute am
Tag an dem Verhandlungen vorbereitet
werden oder ist es eher ein Tag an dem
noch mal der Bizeps gezückt wird
ich denke es ist ganz sicher kein Anlass
für Verhandlungen es ist auch nicht die
Zeit dafür ich sage das ja immer gerne
an die Adresse derer die sogenannte
Verhandlungen fordern ist sie mögen doch
bitte erstmal definieren über was
verhandelt wird und vor allem über den
Kopf der Ukraine hinweg es geht ja immer
noch unser schöner völkerrechtlicher
Grundsatz an Nation ist Nation das heißt
also es kommt nicht auf sogenannte
Einflusssphären wie so mancher
kolportiert an auch nicht darauf wie
groß das Land ist sondern es kommt
darauf an dass es hier um eine souveräne
Nation geht und eine souveräne Nation
entscheidet selber ob und inwiefern sie
verhandelt oder aus dem Kriegszustand
aussteigt was heute signalisiert wird
ist ganz klar erstens militärisch die
fortgesetzte Unterstützung und zwar die
Unterstützung derer auf die es ankommt
ich sage immer scherzhaft zum Glück
hängt die Sicherheit Europas nicht von
Deutschland ab sie sehen hier in diesen
Bildern von Wien die Sicherheit Europas
abhängt nämlich von den USA also man
kann es noch deutlicher sagen das
einzige aus Europa militärisch
zusammenhält ist das European Command
die Amerikaner das was früher die 7
US-Armee war ohne die wenn sie sich auf
Nationen wie Deutschland verlassen
mussten da wäre in Europa aber relativ
schnell Endstation und diese Gleichung
dass die USA letztlich dass das
militärische Rückgrat für Europa sind
die gilt immer noch und die gilt gerade
wieder heute dessen muss man sich klar
sein klar werden es gibt in Zukunft
vielleicht Nationen wie z.B Polen die ja
im Moment stark aufrüsten oder in
Zukunft auch die neue Ukraine nach
diesem Krieg die dann sicher
frontstaaten sein werden gegenüber einem
feindlichen revanchistischen Russland
und vielleicht wird sich das dann
irgendwann ändern aber der der Support
der USA ist ist entscheidend für die
Durchhaltefähigkeit der Ukraine und ich
denke in diesem Kontext muss man die
Bilder sehen
letzte Frage wenn wir auf all das
schauen was wir heute gesehen haben
welche Bilder es heute gab und die auch
ja ausgesendet werden sollen mitsamt der
Botschaften die dahinter stecken Ihr
persönliches Fazit mit Blick auf das was
West-Ost Fernost heute passiert ist
ja ich denke wir sehen die kommende
Weltordnung des 21 jahrhunderts hier
hier herausziehen also ich persönlich
rechne damit dass wir nach diesem Krieg
sicherlich keinen freundliches Russland
bekommen werden ist er dann ultra
nationalistisches Russland sein dass ich
im Wesentlichen von der Idee
europäischer Staatlichkeit von der Idee
des Völkerrechts verabschieden wird es
wird ein Staat sein der sich primär nach
Osten ausrichtet China wird das Ganze
pragmatisch sehen das heißt sie nehmen
gerne die Energie Ressourcen werden sich
ansonsten aber nicht auf auf diese
russischen inneren politischen Spielchen
einlassen und ähm der besten wird
natürlich gezwungen sein an der polnisch
weißrussischen und der Ukraine
russischen und weißrussischen Grenze
eine Abwehr zu errichten das heißt an
neuen Eisernen Vorhang mit befestigten
Grenzen ich denke das wird die Realität
für einen Großteil dieses Jahrhunderts
bleiben